i
[Música]
este fin de semana miles de
manifestantes salieron a las calles de
las principales ciudades de estados
unidos como washington nueva york y
boston pidiendo el final de los ataques
de israel contra la franja de gaza-
manifestantes llevaron pancartas y
banderas pidiendo la libertad para gaza
y el final del apartheid por parte de
israel- varios judíos también
participaron en estas marchas pacíficas
en las que comprar cartas afirmaban no
en mi nombre y solidaridad con palestina
por su parte el presidente de job aiden
habló con benjamín netanyahu y expresó
su apoyo a un cese al fuego
adicionalmente un grupo de 27 senadores
liderados por el judío john soft de
georgia pidió un cese al fuego también
de inmediato entre las dos partes para
prevenir más muertes y más violencia
[Música]
en esta explanada de plaza italia se
concentraba el viernes pasado decenas de
chilenos ataviados con la bandera
palestina para protestar por los
bombardeos que israel está llevando a
cabo en la franja de gaza esta
manifestación fue rápidamente dispersada
por la policía chilena que usó gases
lacrimógenos y carros lanzaaguas para
este martes la federación palestina
convoca a otra manifestación que
recorrerá las calles de santiago y la
que pide a todo el mundo portar también
su bandera palestina y el pañuelo
tradicional árabe ese mismo pañuelo que
portaban los jugadores del club
palestino en su último partido de fútbol
también como señal de protesta los lazos
entre chile y la comunidad palestina son
fuertes aquí reside la comunidad
palestina más importante fuera del mundo
árabe estimada en aproximadamente 500
mil personas que en algunos casos
llegaron a finales del siglo 19
principios del 20 al país algunos de
ellos en este momento ocupan puestos de
poder
[Música]
en méxico diversas organizaciones
sociales como el comité de solidaridad
con los pueblos entre otras han
expresado su condena por los recientes
ataques del ejército israelí sobre la
franja de gaza que han dejado ya cientos
de muertos el pasado sábado 15 de mayo
decenas de manifestantes se congregaron
en el monumento a la revolución en la
capital del país para lanzar consignas
contra los bombardeos y elevar pancartas
con mensajes como esto no es un
conflicto es un genocidio o bien abajo
el muro de la segregación palestina
libre de ocupación reprocharon además lo
que consideraron la tibia reacción del
gobierno mexicano y exigieron romper
relaciones con israel mientras tanto por
la vía diplomática el embajador ante
naciones unidas cuanto amor de la fuente
hizo un llamado a israel a frenar el uso
desmedido de la fuerza sobre la
población palestina y a detener la
destrucción de instalaciones civiles sin
embargo el exhorto también fue para
hamás para frenar el lanzamiento de
cohetes sobre israel
[Música]